il y à 7 ans pratiquement à la même
heure sur le même passage à niveau
le scénario était quasiment le même un
bus scolaire transportant une trentaine
d'adolescents entrait en collision avec
un ter 18 personnes avaient été blessées
dont deux grièvement au cours de
l'accident le chauffeur de car c'était
arrêté précipitamment pour mettre fin à
une bagarre dans le bus
persuadé d'avoir dépassé le passage à
niveau
la collision avait été d'une extrême
violence en 2014 le chauffeur avait été
condamné à trois mois de prison avec
sursis et à une amende pour blessures
involontaires mais surtout après
l'accident décision avait été prise de
supprimer le fameux passage à niveau
classé comme le 11e plus dangereux de
france
les travaux sont considérés comme
chantiers prioritaires par la région les
coûts sont estimés à plus de 25 millions
d'euros actuellement entre 12000 et
15000 véhicules franchissent le passage
à niveau de jonchés chaque jour
[Applaudissements]